call this a for the area of this region
the area of this sector this section of
the circle right there
so the formula that relates all of these
variables here is area equals one-half R
squared times theta so one half R
squared theta now the thing you want to
remember is that theta has to be in
radians so the central angle Espeon
radians so if they give it to you in
degrees convert it to radians if you
need help with that refer to one of my
previous videos about converting the
units from degrees to radians radians to
degrees and want to make sure this is in
Radian so let's do an example let's say
we have a circle like this say the
radius is 4 inches say this central
angle is M PI over 6 radians and we want
to find the area okay so what we're
going to do is area equals 1/2 4 squared
that's the radius squared times the
central angle which is PI over 6 all we
have to do is simplify now and that's
the area of the sector so 1/2 times 16
times PI over 6
you can do some reducing numerator and
denominator let's do that so 2 goes in
here once 2 goes in here 8 2 goes into
both of these 3 & 4 so if you multiply
across you get 4 PI over 3 inches